Let's go back.
We can say that the sun's rays being vertical in Syene, that's not entirely true.
The way we made the calculation, that's about a 20% error.
We saw it was 16% on one side and 24% on the other,
so I'm just going to say it's about 20%.
We're just trying to get a big picture idea of where our error is coming from here.
What about measuring the angle of the sun's rays in Alexandria?
How much error would we get from this measurement?
Let's think about how we did the calculation.
We put a vertical rod upright in Alexandria
and allowed the sun to shine on it, which caused a shadow down here.
By measuring the length of this shadow and the length of this rod,
we could calculate this angle, which we called alpha.
So the only real place for error in this calculation--
well, there's 3 places for error in this calculation.
The first is making sure the rod is vertical.
By simply hanging a weight from a string,
you can assure that something is vertical
because you know that weight will always point straight down,
straight to the center of the Earth.
So this wasn't really something to worry about.
The next comes from measuring the rod itself, measuring the length of the rod.
We know that nothing can be measured to exact precision,
but they had pretty good measuring devices even 2,000 years ago,
so I don't think there's much error introduced in measuring the length of this rod,
and I think we can safely say it's negligible and not worry about it.
Finally, we have measuring the length of the shadow.
When you try to do this experiment at home--
and that will be one of the homework assignments;
we're all going to collect this data together--
you'll find that measuring a shadow length isn't completely trivial.
In fact, shadows are a little fuzzy. It's hard to tell where they begin and where they end.
So actually, there is some error here.
Let's say it's about equal to--I don't know--1 centimeter, which is 1/100 of a meter.
If we're talking about a shadow whose length is 100cm,
that would be a 1% error.
1cm is 1% of 100.
I want to know how can we best reduce the percentage error
with the measurement of the shadow.
Should we make the measurement many times?
Should we use a really, really big rod?
Or should we use many rods of varying length?
Which of these would best reduce the percent error?